europe's digital principles shall guide  our actions and initiatives  access for all to the internet a secure  online space the right to learn digital  skills algorithms that respect people  and the protection of children online  these important principles will  complement the legal rights  that already protect europeans online  like for example the protection of  personal data  or the freedom of expression it puts the  individual at the center  and it will ensure  that people safety and fundamental  rights  are protected  we then want to enshrine these  principles  in a solemn declaration by the european  parliament the council and the  commission  [Music]  you